so I want to talk to you about trace
minerals okay I finally got these in
I've been waiting for these things and
they're amazing now trace minerals are
typically those minerals needed in very
small amounts you don't need a lot of
them maybe probably about micro grams
not like huge amounts like calcium
magnesium but very small amounts so
trace minerals are essential to build
the cells in the body the DNA there's
even studies that show that this thing
called mitochondria turn of human
biology
mitochondria the energy factories that's
where all the metabolism occurs that's
when you burn fat you need that
mitochondria if you're deficient in
trace minerals what happens is the
mitochondria they don't work anymore
they actually age faster so there's all
sorts of studies that show that trace
mineral deficiencies accelerate the
mitochondrial decay and they break down
so here's the problem from 1950 to 1999
certain trace minerals are deficient by
79% okay in other words broccoli for
example had like 130 milligrams of
calcium in 1950 but in 1999 it's like 48
so the soil is becoming more and more
depleted but they only found three
minerals that were deficient and I was
curious like why are they only finally
like three minerals deficient from that
time period then I found out in 1950
that's all they tested for three
minerals they didn't look at all
seventy-four minerals because you need
all these minerals right so I know that
there's a lot of deficiencies even more
than three it's like all of them so the
problem is the farmers are are not
replenishing the nutrients or the the
minerals back into the soil
so other than three minerals it's called
NPK nitrogen phosphorus and potassium if
there's no minerals in the soil
there's no minerals in the plant the
minerals are needed to make the vitamins
there's two types of minerals and when
you go to store GNC and you buy these
minerals what you're really getting is
you're getting rocks and one
calcium carbonate that's like limestone
your body does not absorb rocks so the
absorption rate from these metals these
metallic minerals these rocks these
salts you know like they call them trace
mineral salt they don't absorb like four
percent at the very very most what you
need is plant-based minerals because
typically what happens that the planet
digs down into the soil and it breaks
down the rocks absorbs the rock into the
plant and then we're designed to eat the
plant because the plant is converted
that rock into an easy absorbable
nutrient or mineral
alright so plant-based minerals are
about ten thousand times smaller than
rocks or regular minerals so it'd be
like the equivalent of a let's say we
have a golf ball in the Empire State
Building
so the golf ball will be plant-based
minerals are very small they absorb a
hundred percent of your body so when you
take them to go in like a rocket ship
the problem is where we're going to find
the trace minerals so I found a company
that I got them from which is from a
period of time that went back sixty
million years ago when you have the
prehistoric type plant-based stuff and
what happens that's when the soil is
really really rich that's when we had
all the nutrients so now we can't find
it so I found these minerals that they
actually liquefied them in cold water
processing units and now we can actually
take them in small amounts to actually
get our nutrients and enhance our diet
so I just want to tell you what happened
so I took these minerals last Friday ok
Friday Saturday and Sunday so normally
my son is about he's about a hundred
eighty pounds he's a wrestler I'm a
wrestler but he's pretty strong okay why
was a wrestler so I was pretty strong
and back then but now I'm not I mean he
could just like take me down right so I
took the minerals and I'm wrestling him
on Sunday and I took him down like a rag
doll like the heck he's like dad what's
gotten into you I said I know I just
feel really really strong this is like
you're like the Incredible Hulk
I said thank you so I found that these
minerals help build muscle repair
ligaments tendons they build the
foundation of your cells so I'm like I'm
waking
up in the morning feeling refreshed I'm
sleeping deeper so then I start giving
him to my staff and Roxanna is like what
deck were in those things let's say I
feel so good in the morning I work out a
lot so the trace mineral a gave me think
a little bit more energy especially in
the morning because I do a 6 a.m. boot
camp class so it actually gave me more
like a boost so it was actually and I've
been taking it ever since it's pretty
cool
I'm not like the best eater but I do eat
salads kale and stuff like that just
like I've learned from working here and
I just feel like this is going to give
him one nutrient especially for my hair
my face my nails and stuff like that
stuff that I am very interested in like
personally so I feel like it's going to
help me a lot well I mean I didn't feel
anything initially you know it was just
felt like I was just drinking water and
then the that night I slept a little
better it wasn't a huge huge difference
but I woke up more refreshed than I did
before and then the next night was
better and better and better and it just
got kept on getting better so and also
my energy just added my energy sustain
longer like where I would have a burst
of energy and then sort of mellow out
and then have another burst this time my
energy was it would it was longer
basically some of the purposes of trace
minerals are to help your immune system
I mean if you take trace minerals you'll
knock out a fever like that especially
in infants or little kids
why because trace minerals suppress
viruses
you can't kill a virus because it's not
alive it's a piece of genetic material
wrapped in a sack it comes out of
remission when your resistance is low so
the trace minerals build up your
resistance to infections and viruses so
take that virus and put them right back
in remission and so if you take it a
regular basis you kind of keep the
viruses of stuff at bay so trace
minerals help proteins and what part of
your body's protein you have hair nails
skin collagen that glue that holds your
body together get your joints you have
your eyes it helps prevent macular
degeneration that's so that's a little
thing in the back of the eye that helps
you focus right so we have that so when
you have like all these like weird
symptoms like dry brittle body tissues
you
dry skin bro hair dried out that's just
trace minerals okay so you need about 74
minerals you don't want to get them from
the sea you want to get them from the
plants because they're much better to
absorb
okay so blood building muscle repair
rejuvenation you feel burnt out I reckon
I normally recommend it for people that
are burnt out and because they're not
sleeping and then just kind of wore out
this is really good for a heart repair
so there's many different things that
you can use it for and there's I mean
even increasing fertility wound healing
and diarrhea did you realize that the
number one cause of death worldwide is
diarrhea yeah you would never think that
but it's actually in other countries and
stuff so they get some parasite or
something and then they diarrhea they
lose all their trace minerals those are
electrolytes electrolytes are trace
amounts so they lose them and they die
so how do you stop a diet the personal
diet you've given trace males it stops
it like that alopecia
okay that's your hair that just starts
coming off a little patches that's
autoimmune that's for the adrenal so
trace minerals are really good to
support the adrenal from the stress
responses I always wondered about why
Europeans are thinner than Americans I
wonder why people from Africa have great
bone structure in perfect teeth and I'm
like I mean I had every single in my
teeth kind of cavities growing up so I'm
in Northern Virginia and so I find that
this is a melting pot of all these
different cultures and people so I got a
chance to kind of ask and pull a string
and see what's behind this and even know
these people from Africa are coming from
poor countries they're very rich in the
tradesmen house I really think it's the
trace minerals because if you start out
with good trace minerals and you and you
take them even as an infant or your mom
is breastfeeding you it comes through
the mother you're going to end up with
really good structure musk muscles
longevity health it's going to be way
way better than
America and so you're going to even you
might find when you were growing up you
know a tomato would taste really good
now it's like wax there's no nutrition I
mean it's like very very depleted so
when you eat food it doesn't really
satisfy you why do you think so many
people are craving so many things
especially the salts and the msg and the
foods I mean they put on the street and
make it taste better look at you to eat
it it dilates the taste bud but they're
not really giving the trace minerals
okay
so trace minerals are nutrients and the
purpose of nutrients is this it's to
give your body energy repair the body
growth help you detoxify it's kind of
like a repair mechanism our bodies are
constantly replenishing these minerals
and vitamins we really don't need more
vitamins we need more minerals but we
need trace minerals because I built a
software that analyzes nutrition and and
you could run down a whole profile in on
vitamins and you'll find that most of
them are fulfilled
it's the trace minerals are always
deficient so that's really what's
missing in the soil so there's a big
difference between dirt and soil soil
has all the nutrients it's [ __ ] anyway
typical soils only replace three
minerals NPK nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium sometimes software calcium and
magnesium but mainly its commercial
soils are actually only three so that is
the problem because the nowadays the way
they grow things are very condensed so
they suck all the nutrition out of the
soil and you end up with a depleted
nutrient dense soil so the plant gets
its nutrients from the minerals the
plant turns the minerals into vitamins
without the minerals you don't have the
vitamins and so we're eating food that's
very deficient in nutrients specifically
trace minerals because it's not in the
soil so that's why we have to enhance
because it's so hard to get you would
have to eat 27,000 calories
food to get your trace mineral content
you're required and that's almost
impossible and that's why you're seeing
so many problems with all sorts of
things and I even think obesity is a
problem too with nutrient deficiencies
and even cravings so and it's hard to
find soil it's hard to go I went to the
farmers market to get my my lettuce and
my tomatoes but I can't always do that
so you have to either grow your own food
or get a trace mineral that has all the
the nutrients but make sure it's it's
plant-based minerals not C or metallic
or salts or rocks